so you might ask how did I get this list
of files that I used in my manifest I
could just list every file coming from a
directory listing from my server but I
don't want to grab things like Python
files so the easiest thing to do is to
get files that you know you're going to
need like the images that I knew were
referenced and the JavaScript files and
then walk through one at a time and see
what happens when you try to run the app
from the cache let's try this now let's
take a couple of these files out and see
what happens
let's save the manifest file and go back
and reload now remember even though
we've downloaded a new cache here what
we're looking at over here is not that
uploaded content we need to refresh one
more time and now you'll notice that
when I try to get this file from my
application it just fails now if I had
put in my manifest file under the
network section star that would mean
anything could come from the network I
find is a useful trick to not use
network star because then you can see
what's failing